[拍手]
皆さんこんにちは今日はお時間をいただき
誠にありがとうございますまずは簡単な
自己紹介からさせて
ください私はイギリス出身で小さい時から
アニメが大好きだったので大学で日本語
勉強し数年前に来日しましたここで
どんどん日本語を勉強し今では日本の企業
で務めています
この自己紹介いかがです
かこの外見によく合っていると思い
ますが実は全くの嘘です騙したようで
申し訳ありませんが私は石川出身
です石川県和島市に生まれ小中高大と全て
効率の学校に通い就活をして会社員をした
経験もあります海外に住んだことはまだ
ありません
実際のところ私のような外見をしていて
日本語悠長に話すと最初に申し上げたよう
なバックグラウンドをしているのは違和感
がないと思いますがそれと比べて石川出身
の話には違和感を感じる方がいらっしゃる
のではないでしょう
か日本だと普通とされるこのおいたちに
違和感を感じるのはなぜ
でしょうそれは言うまでもありませんが
この顔がミスマッチしているからだと思い
ます
本日はこの違和感っていうのを起点に私の
ストーリーを共有させていただけたらと
思っています典型的な日本人に見えないと
お国はどちらですかと聞かれることがよく
ありますが私はこの質問に対して戸惑いを
感じなかなか答え方を統一するのに苦戦し
まし
た自分の生まれ育った国故郷は日本です
ただ両親ともイギリス国籍であるため自分
に日本の国籍はありませんかと言って私の
場合は日本にしか住んだことがないので
一言でイギリスと答えるのにも気が引ける
の
です直感では日本と答えたいけれどもこの
外見だと私が日本生まれというのは
なかなか受け入れられませ
んこの回答では物足りないと言わんばかり
に両親の出身国を聞かれあイギリスの子ね
と認識されることがほとんどです
逆にアメリカやロシアなどこの外見にあっ
た国を言ば言えばどこでもいいというのが
事実
です大人となった今はネタとして笑いを
取ったり今の気持ちを言語化する力が突き
始めてきましたが日本しか知らなかった
子供時代の自分にはお国はどこと言われて
日本以外にそもそも思いつくものがあり
ませんでし
ただから日本という自分の答えがが
受け入れられなかった時は母国に突き放さ
れたような気持ちになってその後の旅あ
人生の旅人に大きな悩みの種として現れ
まし
た私にとって外見はどうであれ故郷は石川
県でも度々いやいや元はお国の話よと信じ
てもらえないことの方が多かったので自分
の居場所はここであってはいけないのかと
不安に感じ必死で周りの日本人の身を
見まねをして私も日本人らしくなろうとし
ていまし
た例えば中学校の時は高速とは別で生徒
ルールというのがあって制服の着こなしが
学年によって変わっていたり学年によって
していいこといけないことがあったりして
むしろ先輩からの圧の方が怖いとされる
学校環境でした冬も投稿時にウィンド
ブレーカーのズボをスカートの下に履いて
はいけないというルールがあって膝丈を
超える雪の中私は生足を出してスカート姿
でバスを待っていまし
たそれを見た母親はこんなに寒いのに
バカバカしい風を引くでしょうと言ってい
たんですが全く論理の通らない子春鬼娘の
私と意見のぶつけ合いを重ね私としては
学校に存在する上下関係に対して論理では
説明できなくても波を立たせてはいけない
ということが感覚で分かっていたので親に
は説明できない一種の日本日本文化に適用
していたのです私は外見からしてすでに肩
に入りきれないこともありました
が周りと同じでクラスの行けてる子たちと
同じような制服の着こなしをしたり流行り
の性感剤を買ったりそしてうりのある
髪の毛を毎朝ストレートに直したりと省か
れないためには時間も労力も惜しみません
でし
たまた成長期が来て身長が大幅に伸びた時
も身長まで並外れとは勘弁してくれと思い
ながら無意識に猫背になって周りと世たが
なるべく変わらないように出る悔いとなっ
て打たれないことばかりを重視して毎日を
過ごしていました子供時代の私は今お話し
したように日本人に溶け込むのに精一杯
でしたが親の国にはイギリス私の国は日本
という感覚でしたでも私の両親はうちは
イギリス家庭だとのように宣言していまし
た周りから外人だと指を刺されると母親は
怒って外国人じゃないあ外人じゃない
外国人よと言い張っていましたがこの時私
は心の中で自分は外人でも外国人でもない
なと強い違和感を感じていたのを覚えてい
ますでも向きになっている母親を見守る
ことしかできず私の国は日本だと言い張る
勇気はありませんでした
た行ったところで周りの日本人にも自分の
親にもどうせ認めてもらえないということ
が目に見えていたから
ですどこにも属せないまま周りの顔色を
伺いつつ家の外では日本人らしく家の中で
はイギリス人らしく振る舞うようにしてい
ました二十歳を迎え成人式に出席した際に
は市長から成人する意味大人の責任につい
てお話を伺いまし
たこれには税金や選挙の話が含まれあなた
たちはこういった形で国を担っていくの
ですと話をまとめていましたでもこの時私
は胸がどっしり重くなっていまし
た全人生を過ごした日本という国をよくし
ていきたいという気持ちがあったとしても
外国席の私は選挙に携わることができずあ
選挙権がなく携わることができません
結局どれだけ溶けもうとも結局私はよそ者
であって私の意見はカウントされないのだ
ということを思い知らされました同級生と
混じって成人式に参加している自分が全
否定された気持ちでしたその時を酒井に
日本がダメなら外国人になり切ってやろう
と完全にメンタリティを変えてむしろ日本
に対して反発的になり始めていました
在日外国人の方と友達になり英語中心の
毎日を送り持ち前だったはずのイギリス人
要素を全面的に出していきまし
たイギリス家庭で育ったものの私は祖国に
祖国に関して決して詳しいわけではあり
ませんでしたでもそれが弊害になるとは
思わず積極的に会話に参加していきました
でもこの時初めて気づかされたことそれは
私の知っているイギリスというのは
あくまで両親が教えてくれた祖国のことで
あって80年代には来日していた2人の
視点から見たイギリスだったということ
ですただでさえ限定されていた英国に
関する知識が今度は前提までずれていると
いうことを気づき同年代のイギリス人と
絡んだ際に極端な紅茶好きを除いて私が
いかにイギリス人らしくないかということ
を思い知らされまし
たいわゆる外国人デビューをしたばかりの
私はが似ているから溶け込めると思いきや
話し方がお年寄りみたいだとからかわれ
たりポップカルチャーを元にしたえ
ユーモアが全く通じなかったりそもそも
語彙不足で言葉の意味が分からなかったり
とこっちはこっちで馴染むまでまだまだ
努力が必要だったというのが現実でし
たそれにも関わらず外国人に振り切ってい
た自分は出身を聞かれた時に
イギリスですと一言答えるようになってい
ましたあら日本語が上手ねと言われると
ありがとうござい
ますこうやって本当の自分を見せずに
逃げるようになっていまし
たイギリス人に振り切ってみたものの日本
の田舎しか知らなかった私は世界に関する
知識が極端に少ないことを痛感し世界情勢
や歴史人種差別的な言動に対す理解などが
ゼロに等しく日本にいれば知らなくていい
とされていても西洋の方では常識常識とさ
れているものが私には身についていません
でし
たでも逆に日本の文化や日本人の考え方を
下げ済むように語る方がいるとやけに日本
のことをカに入ったりすることもありまし
たこのことを欧米人の友人に相談した
ところかけられた一言これはジャスミンは
どうせも日本人だから仕方ない
よこれは私にとってイギリス人失格と言わ
れたも同然の釘を刺すような一言でし
た励ましてくれたに違いありませ
んでも日本しか知らないのに私も無理は
ないと諦めていまし
た子供時代は日本人になりきろうとして
受け入れられず今度はイギリス人になりし
たものこちらも無理なのかと途方にくれて
いました日本人かイギリス人かこの2択を
迫られ思考錯誤する年月が続きましたが
25歳を超えて初めて本当にどちらか選ば
なければいけないのかと自問してみまし
た自分にはイギリスでたどってきた家計と
日本という故郷がある片方を選ぶことに
よってもう片方をないがしろにしてしまう
しそもそも選ぶ必要はないのではない
か日本と英国の両方を自分の一部として
持つことに何ら問題はないのではないかと
考えるようになっていまし
た今となっては自分の持っている独特の
世界観両方の文化を自分のものとして
持てることを特別なスーパーパワーとして
認識してい
ます自分に合わない肩に入ろうとするのを
やめ目の目の前にあるのが道なき道であっ
たとしても
その道を自分らしく歩んでいこうと決意し
まし
た私がありのままの自分を受け入れようと
思えるまで30年近くかかりましたが私の
ような境遇に生まれた子供たちは少なく
ありませんこれが私1人のストーリーなら
へえですんでおしまいでいいんですが
アイデンティティに悩まされる子供は
たくさんい
ます日本に絞ってお話をしますが出入国
管理長の計によると観光客を除いた中長期
で滞在する在日外国人のうち0から4歳の
入用時数は私が生まれた1995年には
約5万人が全員日本に残ったとは限りませ
んが私のように戸惑いながら育ったで
あろう子供の数がこんなにも多いこと
そしてその子たちが現在はすでに成人して
社会の一員として生きているということを
お分かりいただきたい
です95年以降の外国席を持つ入用時数の
推移を見てみますとこの20年の間にも
増加していることが分かり
ます日本をホムとする留外国人が増加する
とともにここで人生のスタートを切る外国
籍の子供も私が生まれた年から倍近くに
増えてい
ますまたその在留資格を確認しますと
やはり特別住者永住者定住者など長期間の
滞在が可能な資格を持つ子供の数が半数
以上占めています中にはいずれ出国する
可能性のある子もいるとは思いますが近年
の定住長期滞在傾向が高まっていることを
考えるとその子供たちもこのまま日本国内
で成長期の大半を過ごす可能性も大いに
あると考えることができますこのように
典型的な日本人に見えない子供で日本を
故郷とする子供がどんどん増えている中で
例え国はどちらという一見たいもない会話
が発端だとしても周りの大人たちが無知で
い続けるとその子供を傷つけかねません
これは日本に限った話ではありませんが
何人であっても子供は子供ですしその子
たちが出身地やアイデンティティを表明し
た際に大人が軽率な言動で否定してしまう
と子供は自分の直感や純粋な気持ちそれを
信じられなくなって不安や戸惑いを生んで
しまいます現在は心理学の分野でも様々な
研究が発表されており子供の発言を重ねて
否定することがちのその子の人生で不安症
と関連性があるということも分かってきて
います例え大人にとっては些細な一瞬で
あっても子供にとっては大人の言動1つ1
つ大きな重みがありその行動や反応を見
ながら子供は育つわけなのでこの多様な
社会を生きる中で大人の小さなきり次第が
その子供の先を左右すると言っても過言で
はないと私は考
ます日本国内においても多分化化は確実に
進んでいますがこれはもう未来の話では
ありません本日の私の例から日本で
生まれ育ち教育を受け就職までしている人
がすでにいるということをご理解いただけ
たと思います現在進行系で私のような人は
存在しています
し日本を故郷とする子供も着実に増えて
いる現状をデータで見ることができました
日本育ちの私の立場からすると外国籍の
人々に対する賛成権など法的なインフラ
日本人には多様性がたくさん隠れているの
にそれが知られていない点など母国に
求めることは多くあります逆に来日した
外国人観光客が日本文化に対する
リスペクトにかけていると私も日本人同等
に怒りを感じ
ますさらに言うと外見の変わらない私たち
まで道に扱われてしまうのでこうやって
私たち在日外国人の名まで泥を塗られるん
だと呆れ同じにしないでくれと叫びたく
なることも多々あります外見がどうであれ
ルーツやホーム身に染みつきている文化は
10人トロであって私のような一見全然
違う外見であっても日本人と同じ感覚で見
ているものもあるというのが事実です今日
私がここに登壇させていだいたのは外国人
に見える人でもあらゆる形でこの国を
ホームとする人である可能性が大いにある
ということを生きた証として提示したかっ
たのと子供が自分のコアとなる故郷や
アイデンティティ気持ちを主張した際に
周りの大人が何も考えずに否定することに
よってその子は自分を疑ってしまい不必要
に不安を生んでしまうという現実を知って
いただきたかったからです理想を語った
ところで現実に課題はたくさんあることは
承知です今日の私が今日のあなたに伝え
たいことそれはこの開けた国際社会を
生きる時代に大人として無知であることが
子供を傷つけているということです変化を
生み出せるのは私たち大人なので世界中で
多様がが進む中で外見1つで決めつける
体制を見つめなし大人として責任ある言動
を取ってほしいという思いを投げかけ
ます私自身この現代を生きる1大人として
1人でも多くの方の固定概念を覆すために
そして私にとっては道なき道がこれから
生きる子供たちにとってはしっかり舗装さ
れた安心できる道になることを願ってまず
出身を聞かれたらイギリスですと簡単な
答えで逃げるのを
やめ日本生まれです石川県出身ですと胸を
張って答えますこの旅はご清聴いただき誠
にありがとうございまし
た